what did it feel like having everybody
back together kind of looking around
like the squad is back together like
great you know trippy colin trevorrow
was our captain
he was not only a producer and the
writer of the first world movie and so
had this whole trilogy in his mind over
the last decades i think and cook cooked
it up and how do we make this whole
thing work so it really
is satisfying and delicious to people it
was amazing and he was the just like pat
riley i guess you know or a great coach
kind of
sets a tone he's spectacular and very
collaborative generous kind sweet and
even though the thing is a tremendous
responsibility and epic
and we were under the coved
challenges he was leader his leadership
was tremendous and his coolness
he's been
uh spectacular we made a terrible
mistake doomsday clock might be about
out of time
everybody wanted you back people were a
little upset they were a little
irritated that we didn't see enough of
you in the last movie how did it feel to
come back and finish out
amazing and
i was grateful and appreciative i mean
look i mean geez but just amazing i you
know i can't believe it and steven
spielberg come on he's the godfather of
this whole thing and still
to this day and having had the
experience that i did with him
29 years ago long before you were born
was uh you know uh amazing uh it changed
me forever and working with laura dern
and sam neal just great actors and great
people
uh to be back with them for the first
time since then yeah i'm amazing
they said this was the end for this
group yes yeah well
yeah well the story the story line this
year
yes but could we carry on some folks
that we want some people survive well
who knows
who knows we we don't know anything you
know but i'll bet
yes if i had to if i
looked into my crystal ball
uh
nothing is definitive but i'll bet yeah
if people are interested
and dinosaurs are
always cool always interesting aren't
they i wasn't when i was a kid so you
know after we finished this story with
these interesting characters that
michael crichton created and bryce
dallas howard and chris yeah i hope we
haven't seen the last of them but the
wanda wise is in this and how about
mamadou aceh and uh the great omar c is
back in this and
v d wong you know yes those characters i
would pay any price for a ticket to be
first in line to see
any kind of continuing story story
isabella sermon is in this it was in the
last one oh my golly for most of us we
grow older and we just grow older you've
grown older and you grew cooler to a new
generation embraced you and loved you
and now you have become this
guy that is so loved by kids people's
kids
what is that like oh that's so sweet
um for you to say um
you know i'm happy as a clam
i don't know i'm a lucky guy i um i i
dreamed of being an actor when i was a
kid
right around ninth grade
taking a couple of summer classes and
stuff i was i got obsessed with i would
take a shower every morning we had a
glass door on the shower and it would
steam up and it was just because it was
a secret
i would write on the shower please god
let me be an actor and then before i
left i would wipe it off so my parents
or anybody else wouldn't see anybody
knew i didn't want anybody to know it
was embarrassing or i don't know what
and i was so was so
kind of um
sacred to me or precious or i don't know
what it was an obsession and anyway
i've gotten a chance to do it so what
you're talking about the fact that
i've gotten a chance to do it
and it still feels interesting and
delicious and creative to me is a great
gift and the people are
potentially interested is a wonderful
thing
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home you made a promise
to a dinosaur
yeah what
the dinosaurs are such an important part
of this have you have you fallen in love
with the dinosaurs do you can you rattle
off a bunch are there a lot of dinosaurs
that are your favorites or is it yeah i
yes i i don't know that i know much
about them
my kids are
all kind of kids know you know more than
i do about them and alan grant's
character knows knows everything about
them
though i've always been in love with
dinosaurs we had a i took special art
classes and we went through carnegie
museum in pittsburgh and they had i
think the biggest display of bones
reassembled bones in this lighted
gorgeous marble hallway
spectacular and i read this book about a
kid who found an egg in his backyard
that hatched a triceratops
and that dinosaur was the first one we
saw that stan winston who won the oscar
for that work was manipulating on the
set so it looked like a real triceratops
and now john nolan who did the creature
shop on this one that my kids visited in
pinewood studios saw them put together
the teeth of the many new amazing uh
better than ever dinosaurs that they
have now
i i love a lot of them you know that my
kids saw i showed my kids the first one
and the spitter
uh oh yeah
yeah that and it doesn't spit
they got a kick out of that they thought
that was scary and funny and they're
gonna see in the movie theaters this
movie they've never been to a movie
theater before they're seven and almost
seven and five they've never been to a
real movie theater they saw the first
ones on tv so i'm gonna take them to the
bar i'm gonna stand on the back of the
first i plan the first weekend and i
hope people are enjoying it and filling
up the theater and i'll take them to see
it
that's disgusting
can i take you back though for a second
the fly yes sir we're about to hit a
milestone for that right is it well we
need 86 no 866 so what are we going to
do
right
sure david cronenberg i ran into him
recently you know in the last few years
i i loved working with him that was a
creative landmark for me yeah and uh and
it uh i he he really rang the bell with
that one and uh you know i i like that
part that was a great great movie i've
gotten pretty good at it haven't i
yeah it's almost second nature
stop biting my nails
i seem to be stricken by a disease with
a purpose wouldn't you say
maybe not such a
bad disease after all
what do you remember most about that
what is your what is the thing that
endures for you about that movie the fly
it was
heartbreakingly romantic and
tragic in a way and
chris wales got the oscar for that stuff
they did on me and all
into a half-life person but david
cronenberg is just a great um director
and he's an unusual and unique uh artist
and it was lovely working with him gina
davis was spectacular in it
uh i love the whole thing we did it in
toronto where my current wife is from
and i spend time in toronto now on you
know you know holidays and stuff like
that uh it was very special
[Music]
you